Lots of information about BPC157 for fast tissue repair and immunity response, so BPC157 is a peptide,
and we've talked about peptides on this before. There is a lot of information about peptides coming out.
That is, you can get that in an injectable form, and you can now get this in an oral form.
Are these good for cancer? The answer is yes and no. You have to be really careful with these peptides
for cancer, because it does stimulate growth. Now, depending on the cancer, I've tested people
on it, and I have some cancer people on these peptides, but it's a minor number. So you do have to
be careful with cancer using peptides. Am I all for using peptides with other issues that are
non-cancer related? Oh, absolutely. So it's a good stimulus for growth and regeneration,
but you do have to be cognizant of you don't want to stimulate excess growth with cancer.
So that brings it to another, you know, bring it all the way back to the first combat of
you could go be going to a practitioner that is, let's say, oh, just started using peptides
and I see these great results for this and that, and then you come in with why I have cancer. Well,
you should use these peptides. This is really elbow, this person. Okay, well,
something that you would do for somebody who has heart issues, you don't do with cancer.
Some things you would do with person with autoimmune issues, you don't do with cancer.
Some things you do with a person with, you know, whatever, cancer is its own ball of wax,
and you know, you have to know, you know, there are certain things you don't want to do with cancer.
So, um, just be careful of that.